whatever reason why does Brazil have so
many trans people they like it was like
Brazil and the Philippines like what is
going on the music I'm telling you
they're using the music to to hit the
Latino Community I'm telling you ever
seen oh my gosh yeah they are L probably
the probably the surgery is quite cheap
over there as well if you fancy getting
it done yeah you can get it done and so
but it's like the
music that is literally lyric that's
what they're doing it's it's really
strange I mean I've I've talked
about this before in the past like the
reason that like we haven't been
infected with lesbians too much at least
in the Mexican Community is cuz we we
used to have a a star it's really sad
she got killed by a lesbian woman